bonjour nicolas
bonjour au vu des commandes à l'est où
ça va bien et vous même qu'on me parle
de microbes furtif j'ai quelques doutes
aujourd'hui voilà on surveille quand la
main il faut rester prudent même si on
voit que ça arrange en grande bretagne
en tout cas c'est une semaine décisive
pour le gouvernement sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire avant le passage
demain on l'a vu de la loi devant le
conseil constitutionnel
que pouvez-vous nous en dire ce matin
une colère bien ce que je peux vous en
dire cher magali c'est que ce matin je
ne suis pas à ibis à en train de me
dorer la pilule entre deux piña colada
pour faire cet édito sur un transat qui
co responsable non je bosse depuis chez
moi alors même que je n'avais pas à
mettre en place - un protocole de
shadocks pour tous les enseignants et
les parents d'élèves de ce pays ma
grille alors oui elle a mal commencé la
semaine car vous l'avez compris je parle
bien entendu de dj blanc caire qui est
en train de s'embourber dans une
polémique qui fait tache d'huile avec
autant de dégâts qu'un gros baigner bien
gré se glisser dans la poche intérieure
de son costume alors oui vous me direz
la galère on est un peu loin de la crise
sanitaire mais pas tant que ça car le
week-end mielleux 2 jean michel je m'en
bats les arts a pris des airs de
déflagration dans ce pays et pour moins
que ça outre manche n'importe quel
ministre aurait posé sa démission illico
presto et sans entretien préalable mais
qu'est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant dans
cette affaire eh bien elle est
révélatrice en réalité de l'amateurisme
et d'un certain dilettantisme de la part
du gouvernement alors que les français
sont concassés par des mesures
coercitives et liberticide depuis deux
ans l'ibiza gates est à lui seul la
preuve d'une déconnexion politique alors
que l'école est à deux doigts d'exploser
l'hôpital est à un doigt de s'effondrer
et des millions de français à un cheveu
le dire stop à cette folie enfin on
passera vite sur le débat de l'ibiza
gate animé mardi soir par la journaliste
anna cabana qui est aussi les poules de
l'épreuve 2 sur 2 jean mini blank r
alors ça magalhaes ça va pas nous aider
entre nous à faire remonter l'amour pour
notre profession dans le coeur des
français enfin bon un bon donc vous
estimez que c'est un caillou de plus
dans la chaussure du gouvernement ou
alors un beignet bien gressus bien de
rester dans la poche du gouvernement
selon dans sa gestion sanitaire vient
des deux alors oui mais là ce n'est plus
d'un caillou magalhaes et un gros gros
gros menhir posé devant le bureau des
manuels macron car on voit bien que
depuis deux semaines de passes vaccinale
est de moins en moins soutenu par les
français selon l'ifop tout comme cette
politique sanitaire devenu carrément
dingue et pour cela il fallait faire
entrer très gros efforts que j'ai faits
je me concept de tolérance et de
résilience pour regarder ces derniers
jours sur certaines chaînes concurrentes
plutôt favorables au pouvoir en place de
plus en plus de commentaires qui ont
clairement changé de bord le vent
médiatique commence sérieusement à
tourner contre sa stratégie suicidaire
du gouvernement pour discriminer vous le
savez les millions de français dès la
semaine prochaine si le conseil
constitutionnel donnait son aval alors
que plusieurs pays sont en train de
lever les mesures sanitaires de façon
drastique le virologue macron poursuit
une stratégie sanitaire totalement
ubuesque hd 10 et par exemple nos amis
espagnols ont décidé de traiter le colis
de 19 communes grippe idem pour les
norvégiens qui ont défilé de l'armée
approche en grande bretagne on le sait
maintenant le pass le vide ce rallye de
lever d'ici la fin du mois au vu la
situation il y en israël est rappelez
vous un pays qui avait été cité un
exemple pendant des mois et des mois et
des mois la stratégie sanitaire du
gouvernement de neuf talibés net a elle
aussi radicalement changer d' approche
est chez nous alors que le au micro ont
reflué n'a pas entraîné deux surchage
hospitalière vous glisser dans le
reportage la belle équipe
d'épidémiologistes qui lui sert de
gouvernement nous bassine avec ce pass
vaccinale liberticide inique et
totalement inutile alors allez
comprendre magali et comment vous
expliquer alors qu emmanuel macron
veille à tout prix maintenir ce post
vaccinale pour les français alors là on
passe du menhir au noeud du problème
là-bas c'est la question centrale sains
que chaque français doit se poser ce
matin devant son café alors certains
éditorialistes mettre ça sur le compte
vous savez cela stratégie politique à
nous expliquant que mc ren resserre la
vis et qu'à quelques semaines de la
présidentielle il va tout ouvrir et
comme ça il pourra récupérer ou le savez
les lauriers de sa belle gestion
démocratique cette crise sanitaire alors
moi c'est unis possèdent très
sincèrement que je ne partage pas car il
ya quand même quelque chose qui me
chiffonne bon je passe très vite
assurent le spectacle
ridicule comment faire des
parlementaires pôle france sur le vote
de cette loi et les non-réponses abrupte
du gouvernement à porter aux rares et
courageux parlementaires de l'opposition
qui ont peut-être contenter perdant de
contester d'amender cette fameuse loi
ayant et ce qui me chiffonne c'est leur
ce refus de l'amendement ce sans cesse
de la députée anne laure blain pour
enlever du pass vaccinale les lieux de
démocratie comprenez un la
présidentielle et les législatives à
venir ça c'est une question cruciale
pour l'avenir de la souveraineté pleine
et entière du peuple français car le
vote à distance est une épée de damoclès
qui pèse sur la tête de tous les
français qui ont fait le choix de ne pas
faire vacciner ou pas totalement enfin
en somme les pas tout à fait vacciner
vous savez on sait plus trop là et ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux rappelez
vous qu'on nous a dit la main sur le
coeur jamais de passes annie terre
jamais de passes vaccinale mais
aujourd'hui la question se pose sur les
pressions prochaines élections surtout
depuis que gérald darmanin le miz
l'intérieur et laurent fabius le
président du conseil constitutionnel a
dit han ils se sont rencontrés et a faim
de jeu site que le gouvernement élabore
de nouvelles mesures d'organisation qui
apparaîtrait rendu nécessaire par la
crise sanitaire fin de citation alors le
pire est toujours à craindre avec
emmanuel macron et en faisant traîner le
coc vidailhan scénarisant la panique
j'en avais parlé il ya quelques semaines
il y à vraiment des risques que nous
glissions dans une farce démocratique
par procuration et comme l'exprimé
napoléon bonaparte en son temps la bonne
politique est de faire croire au peuple
qu'ils sont libres a à laquelle j'ajoute
mois surtout en leur faisant
terriblement peur qui en se moquant
d'eux magali merci beaucoup à vous est
surmené nicolas vous avez droit à un
petit week-end à ibiza où la corde
exactement
merci beaucoup en tout cas c'était
l'édito politique de nicolas vidal